so we were dying to ask you of of the
flying that you do yeah what percentage
of it is on private jets these days
it's pretty high
Are you ashamed of that I mean it's a
little you're a little embarrassed by it
but also well here's here's the real
like the absolute real real truth of
this
the tour that I have been on I'm coming
everywhere yes
yeah I'm coming everywhere World Tour
is literally I'm talking logistically
logistically impossible to do this
amount like this these shows if you look
at the weeks and the amount of shows of
the amount of cities you could not I I
would I would have to reduce the tour to
do it commercially it wouldn't be the
same tour it literally you can't go I'm
doing Kansas City Cheyenne Eugene
Ottawa Providence you know like you
wouldn't be able to do it commercially
like the only way you can do that
touring is to Charter because you're
literally going from the show to the
airport to fly to the city so that
you're there like you'd have to do three
connections on some of those we would
miss flights now I don't do every flight
like that
um there's there's weeks where we go all
right
I'll fly the you know it was like I was
flying to Toronto and I was like you
know what I'll leave the day before and
fly commercially it was no big deal if I
fly to LA from Austin there's so many
flights I'm like I'll take a commercial
flight but on the the routing of the
tour it's mostly Charter yeah
do can you fly Charter doing theaters
does it make sense economically it
depends two theaters a night
yes or like if you were consistently
selling out two theaters a night would
it make sense to fly private
and and the answer would be well it
really is and it depends scenario
because
what I mean by theater like first of all
there's different size theaters like all
this is very so it's like 3000 and above
you probably can yes if you're doing 3
000 seats a theater that's a pretty good
sized theater that means you're doing 6
000 tickets a night and you're doing
that a few nights like three nights a
week four nights a week yeah you could
do it you still would probably it's so
expensive you would still probably go
back and forth meaning like you take the
commercial ones when it makes sense it
is extraordinarily expensive but here's
the thing the way you if you look at it
like the way I'm explaining you're
taking that Charter flight to make money
it's not just for like the flex or the
luxury of the flight you're actually
going like this flight is allowing me to
go make money in this other yeah you
know that's our goal we want to do it
you know are you still getting burnt out
flying private uh the same way you would
commercial or not the same I mean you
the the biggest convenience you find
from a charter flight people you usually
think of it as like when you see it you
you know you see the inside of it you're
like oh my God it is the fact that when
the flight's at 10 A.M you could pull up
at 9 45 and that when you land you
literally go from the tarmac to the
hotel it's the time saving yeah yeah
it's like it feels like
um I'm sleeping all the way reclined oh
yeah and also like sleeping in that
morning instead of getting up three
hours before you need to be at the
airport so like it's it's that you
actually feel like you time travel like
you land you like I can't believe we
we're here now like you know we're like
or you're in the next city you're
performing in two hours after the show
that just ended in another city so
you're like oh we're here now like you
can't believe that you're there that
quickly that's the part of it that
becomes you're like this is so great I
don't want to give this up but it is
it is
extremely expensive it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude